Anxiety.
Some people hear the term and roll their eyes immediately,
others know what an incredibly real
thing it is. Many people
who seem successful,
are actually suffering from High Functioning Anxiety.
And just because
it's not a formally recognized diagnosis,
it shouldn't be something you have to live with.
By this point, you may already know that your anxiety
pushes you forward instead of holding you back.
While in certain circumstances, this can be helpful,
that doesn't mean it isn't without its lasting
effects. To help you understand this
condition, Psych2Go shares with you, 5 facts
you need to know about High Functioning Anxiety
1. It's not easy to see
Often times, someone with High Functioning Anxiety
appears very driven and successful.
Your anxiety makes you efficient,
your work is delivered on time,
you arrive early and are immaculately just,
and even seem to have endless amounts of energy.
But what people can't see,